-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
I'm Steve Higgins,
and we're about to play a game
called "Pop Quiz."
-♪ Pop quiz,
pop, pop quiz ♪
♪ Pop quiz ♪
-Wow. Our first contestant is
the host of "The Tonight Show."
It's Jimmy Fallon.
-Hey, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And his opponent voices
Mario
in "The Super Mario Bros.
Movie."
Say hello to Mr. Chris Pratt.
-Whoo-hoo!
It's a-me.
-All right, gentlemen,
the rules are simple.
Above you are two warp pipes,
both of which are clogged
with a mystery substance.
[ Audience laughs, murmurs ]
Ooh.
And because Mario
is a plumber,
each of you have been fitted
with custom-made plunger hats.
Now, I will ask you
a series of questions
related to video games.
And if you get an answer wrong
or if your opponent
gets an answer right,
your chair will be risen closer
and closer to the pipe.
And the first person
to reach the top of the pipe
and plunges their pipe loses,
and whatever's clogging the pipe
will be dumped upon you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right. Any questions?
-Well, I was --
-Okay, great.
Chris, you'll be first.
-Good luck.
-Super Mario Bros.
-Boom!
Let's see the answer!
[ Ding! ]
Yes! Super Mario Bros.!
-Wow.
That was a hard question.
I mean, James.
Oh, yo!
-[ Laughs ]
-How was that a hard question?
It's basically every video game
right there.
-Right. It was hard.
That was a difficult question.
-Alright.
-Now, here's your question.
-Yeah.
Oh, good luck.
-Good luck, James.
-Yeah.
[ Tense music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
Who's the creator?
-I mean, I'm a Nintendo nerd.
I'm going to say Miyamoto?
-Judges?
[ Ding! ]
Yes!
Shigeru Miyamoto.
Chris.
Ready?
-[ Grunts ]
[ Video game sounds play ]
Yeah. Ohh!
He's more man than you. Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-Wow.
-Hurt my leg.
-My God.
-Oy!
-God.
-[ Laughing ] What's the name --
Chris?
-Yes.
This is a hard one.
-Pfft!
-Travel across 1800s America?
-Yeah.
-Okay, Now I'm going to phone
a friend on this -- uh, myself.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Hello? Yeah, uh, is that --
I think it's, uh, Oregon Trail?
-Let's see.
Let's see the answer.
Oregon Trail! Yes!
-Hey!
I played that at school.
-Oh, my God.
-I played that in school.
-You died of dysentery.
You got to say --
-He died of a snake bite.
-Ready, Jimmy?
-You're going up.
Ohhhhh, my gosh!
Okay, Jimmy,
next question is for you.
You know this.
-Well, first, I want to give
a shout-out to my...
-[ Laughs ]
-...my buddy Weasel
back at home in Boston.
You know, I love you, Weaz.
Uh, you're talking about
EA Sports. Come on.
-All right,
let's see the answer.
-Electronic Arts.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay. Chris.
Oh, my God. So close.
-Aaaah!
♪ So close ♪
-If it's in the game --
-Alright, Chris.
Next question is to you.
-Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
-Not "what," like his name.
Like, what is his name?
Not what.
-Blinky.
-Inky.
-Pinky and...
[ Drumroll ]
It's kind of ra--
I don't know.
I'm going to
have to take a guess.
Uh, Juanita?
-[ Laughs ]
-Juanita.
-Jimmy, do you know
the answer?
-I do, but it's not --
It doesn't rhyme.
It's like Gary or something.
Or Paul or something.
-Let's see. Judges,
let's see the answer.
-If it's Gary, I'm gonna be --
-It's Clyde!
Oh, Chris. One more.
Ohh, so close!
-Oh, my God.
-Jimmy.
-[ Laughs ]
-Next question is for you.
-Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
Clyde.
Yes. Yes.
-...not Trump...
-Q-Bert.
You're just gonna jump
right on it? Q-Bert?
Let's see the answer.
[ Ding! ]
Yes!
-Q-Bert.
♪♪
[ Laughing ] Oh!
Oh, my gosh.
Chris.
-Are you kidding me?
-Next question is for you.
-What, does his head
gotta go in the pipe?!
-Well, he's got to go
in the pipe.
And that's not -- Trust me.
-For heaven's sakes.
-You don't want to get
that dumped on your head.
[ Balloon pops ]
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
Laughter! His laughter!
His laughter,
that's what got him!
He's a good sport.
-Let's see the slow-mo of that!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
-Chris Pratt, everybody.
The champion!
Go see "Super Mario Bros."
in theaters this Wednesday
and IMAX.
My thank-you to Chris Pratt.
We'll be right back with
More "Tonight Show," everybody.